how's it going everybody
so the Russo brothers are at it again
possibly dropping some more clues about
when we could see the first official
trailer for Avengers 4 the Russo
brothers have been known to troll fans
very very hard and they're pretty
cryptic sometimes when it comes to their
Instagram and Twitter posts they know
that their fans monitor their accounts
like hawks and yesterday we got a new
post from them they posted a picture of
the Infinity Ward logo and the caption
read want to win free tickets to an
infinity war screening and Q&A with us
check out the Collider article link in
bio
now at first you may think this really
isn't anything but if you click on the
link and go to colliders page you'll
learn a little bit more about this
screening and Q&A with the Russo
brothers if you go to the page you'll
learn that it's at Arclight Hollywood in
the Cinerama Dome so this isn't some
small deal it's a pretty big deal but
the question is why why are they
screening infinity war and then doing a
QA after well if you go to the page
you'll find out that this screening is
on November 28th this is when the
trailer is said to come out right around
this date November 29th is the one-year
anniversary since the first Avengers
infinity war trailer came out is this a
coincidence or could a select few
hundred people actually get to see the
trailer the day before it comes out now
of course this is just speculation but
all of the evidence that we've gotten so
far concerning the Avengers 4 trailer
says that it's gonna come out around
this time we just got the prelude comic
for Captain Marvel in which we found out
that the prelude for Avengers 4 is going
to be coming out on December 5th and
they always release the trailer before
they release the prelude so the prelude
doesn't give away too many spoilers and
November 28th is exactly one week before
December 5th when the prelude comes out
so it does seem like everything is
lining up for the trailer to come out
either November 28th or on November 29th
which again would be the one-year mark
since the first infinity war trailer
came out so this is it everybody the
trailer is coming it's almost here so
let me know how excited you are how much
you're freaking out in the comments down
below and I'm starting a new giveaway
I'm giving away a copy of The Avengers
and infinity war art book along with the
art book the winner will also get a copy
of infinity war Deadpool 2 or ant-man
and the wasp and some special
posters as well to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]